winning the Student Academy Award was
one of the highlights of my life when
you make a film the farthest thing fair
in mind is how it's going to be received
by the public and you're just trying to
make it work in the moment on set I came
to filmmaking through other artistic
mediums I was drawing from age to trying
to draw all the time and eventually I
wanted to be pirate and that was that
was what all kids want to be right but I
thought maybe practically speaking I
should try to be an actor because they
get to play pirates high school I
started writing stuff that I wanted to
act in and then writing acting and
drawing led me very naturally to
filmmaking
when I was in seventh grade I did a 40
minute crazy stream-of-consciousness
comedy thing with my friend where we
need to played about 20 roles and I
think that's when I realized this is
what I wanted to do when you start
making movies as a young filmmaker and
you start thinking about how you're
gonna get your work out into the world
and get it seen the Student Academy
Awards quickly becomes the the way to go
to win for me was an incredibly
emotional moment I felt like my heart
but like went up into my throat you know
I mean and I could feel all the support
in the room but also just a moment of
personal triumph because it was
something that I had known about since
junior high school and I never thought I
would be sitting in that chair hearing
my name said by N's wick of all people
are gold medal in their to filmmaking
goes to Julianne Higgins it was really
inspiring to be around the people that
do what they love as their career I met
June Foray the voice of rocky and rocky
and bullwinkle it was it was full of
experiences like that where I just kind
of couldn't believe I was there it was
really great to be able to see the
different guilds around town and sort of
imagine the people that worked on the
film being able to be a part of those
organizations and now a year later I am
part of the DGA which is kind of cool as
well of all the festivals and events
that we had to get fortunate to be part
of the Student Academy Awards felt to me
like the most inclusive of the team
members and it really felt like we were
all included in winning it wasn't just
me and I think that's really important
because it really is a group effort to
make a film and I feel like we all
finished the week feeling like we were
all part of it we were all
it was so gratifying to see how well the
phone was received I think we played at
about 50 festivals over the course of
the year one about 25 Awards and my film
being a film in another language that
takes place in another country it was
really gratifying to see that that story
could be meaningful for people all over
the world my film won the college
Television Award Best Drama and Best
Director and the presenter of the Best
Director award was the producing
director of house Greg at anus and Greg
had seen the film obviously and really
admired it and wanted to know what I was
interested in doing so he invited me to
shadow the show and watch him work and
learn as much as I could from him and
four months later he offered me an
episode of the show to direct winning
the Student Academy Award really gave me
the credibility to allow Greg Katinas to
pitch me to the studios and networks
that produce house in order to get me
that job it was a really special show to
work on the opportunity to direct house
changed my life movies can change people
and I really really believe that and I'm
trying to tell the stories that I think
need to be told the most important thing
you can do as a young filmmaker
is just start creating material start
practicing it takes years and years to
find your voice I certainly don't feel
like I'm there yet I feel like I'm I'm
well on my way but I have a lot to learn
and I hope I never stop learning
you